[Music]
in 1998 the community of physicists
received a shock the shock is two teams
of astronomers had figured out through
observations of distant supernovae that
the expansion of the universe which
everybody knew about since Hubble in
1929 that the expansion of the universe
was not slowing down as everybody
expected but it was speeding up it was
going faster and faster shock now why
did people expect the expansion to be
slowing down well it's something that
you've experienced right if you take an
apple and you throw it up Earth's
gravity slows it down gravity pulls
things together so everyone thought that
the galaxies themselves their mutual
gravitational attraction would slow down
the expansion of the universe over time
but these astronomers their observations
showed a very different picture their
observations showed that the galaxies
are all rushing away from each other
faster and faster and faster over time
this is as if you took an apple and you
threw it up and instead of it going
slower and slower the Apple goes faster
and faster now how can you explain that
weird observation well the best
explanation that we have to date is
something called dark energy dark energy
is kind of a diffuse energy that fills
space and according to Einstein's
general theory of relativity that
diffuse energy can yield a repulsive a
repulsive version of gravity what would
that mean so if this steam like entity
here is the dark energy made white so
you can see it it yields a repulsive
gravitational push that pushes the
galaxies apart causing them to move away
from each other faster and faster and
faster overtime an amazing thing is if
you go back into the historical archives
of physics in 1917 Albert Einstein
himself introduced something called the
cosmological constant he introduced it
because he realized that this number
would yield an energy filling space that
would yield a repulsive gravitational
push now he introduced it way back then
for the wrong reason he introduced it
because he wanted this outward push of
gravity to counteract the usual inward
attractive pull of gravity canceling it
out yielding a static universe that's
what he thought he didn't think that
space was expanding back then in 1917
when it was learned that space is
expanding he threw the cosmological
constant away and as famously reported
he called it his greatest blunder and
the amazing thing is post 1998 we now
need a version of that cosmological
constant we need that repulsive gravity
to explain the accelerated expansion of
the universe so in some sense it tells
us that even some of I'm Stein's wrong
ideas if you wait long enough they turn
out to be right
you